[Musique]
avec vous Hélène frad bien sûr bonjour
Hélène à la une de la presse Hélène
comme du journal l'ouverture à
sharm-elcher en Égypte de la Conférence
mondiale de l'ONU sur le climat la COP
27 un sommet pour tenter de relancer la
lutte contre le réchauffement climatique
une cop27 pour sauver la planète rien
que ça c'est du moins ce canon ce matin
le quotidien égyptien à Lyon
pour cette occasion le quotidien site
longuement le président égyptien Abdel
fatal Sissi invitant les participants à
sommet à prendre la mesure des défis
sans précédent je le cite auquel la
planète est confrontée de son côté Al
Masri à Lyon autre quotidien égyptien
cite lui le ministre des Affaires
étrangères égyptiens ça m'est Choukri
qui préside cette COP 27 et qui a
annoncé que le moment était venu
d'appliquer enfin les promesses de
passer enfin des paroles aux actes en
finir avec les alors que les pays en
développement réclament on le sait des
dédommagements financiers pour les
catastrophes climatiques qu'il subissent
le délit télégraphe annonce que le
Royaume-Uni envisage cite de telles
réparation un engagement qui reviendra
d'ailleurs aux nouveaux premiers
ministres britanniques Richie sunnac qui
a finalement fait le déplacement après
la grosse polémique sur sa possible
absence à ce sommet d'après le finance
should Times les États-Unis disent de
leur côté travailler sur un projet pour
amener les grandes entreprises mondiales
à dégager des fonds pour permettre aux
pays en développement de réduire leurs
émissions de CO2 un projet qui sera
détaillé durant ce sommet par l'envoyer
américain pour le climat John Kerry le
Royaume-Uni et les États-Unis
renvoyaient deux ados ce matin par de
Guardian qui rappelle qu'avant de
prendre de nouveaux engagements les pays
développés les pays du Nord feraient
bien de contribuer à hauteur des
engagements qu'ils ont déjà pris le
quotidien britannique rappelle que les
pays riches sont loin d'avoir payé la
totalité des 100 milliards de dollars
par an premier en 2009 jusqu'en 2020
année où les États-Unis par exemple
n'auraient payé que 7 milliards et demi
de dollars sur les 40 milliards premiers
qu'attendre Hélène de cette cop27 si
toutefois on peut en attendre quelque
chose la presse internationale et
mitigée le quotidien espagnol et le païs
estiment que oui les pays riches doivent
s'acquitter de leur dette envers les
pays en développement pour ces pays qui
sont les mois responsables en réalité du
changement climatique et clé se met sur
le climat reste essentiel car sans eux
la dégradation de la situation au cours
des 30 dernières des trois dernières
décennies des 30 dernières années aura
été bien pire plus sceptique les
dessinateurs de presse soulignent pour
beaucoup d'entre eux en tout cas le
décalage entre les discours et les
parents et les actes et c'est avoir avec
ce dessin de l'Argentin qui montre un
orateur à la tribune de la COP 27 les
pieds dans l'eau faisant un geste
d'impuissance dans celui du néerlandais
tiers de Royat les participants se
disputent autour de la table avec des
statistiques affolantes tandis que la
planète brûle dans la cheminée et que
leur tourne et plusieurs dessinateurs de
presse expriment également leur
indignation de voir le président
égyptien Abdel fatal Sissi accueillir
cette cop27 alors que la machine
répressive égyptienne tourne
actuellement à plein régime et la
question des droits de l'homme en Egypte
on y reviendra dans le décryptage avec
Bruno Darroux tout à l'heure à la Une
également Hélène les élections de
mi-manda aux États-Unis c'est demain
mardi inscrit un regard avec beaucoup
d'attention et d'inquiétudes ici en
France on a les risques de violence
outre-atlantiques font la Une notamment
du gratuit 20 Minutes qui cite un
chiffre inquiétant publié récemment par
la presse américaine
291 29
élue sur 568 le nombre de candidats
républicains au Congrès ayant refusé de
reconnaître la victoire de Joe Biden à
la présidentielle ou au minimum on
semait le doute sur son résultat des
discours qui alimentent le risque de
violence après ces mitters d'après le
gratuit inquiétude également du côté du
Parisien Aujourd'hui en France qui
évoque le climat de tension extrême qui
règne actuellement dans le pays ce pays
où les démocrates et les républicains ne
se parlent plus et où le président de
Joe Biden et son ex oreval républicain
de notre Trump semble rejouer le match
de 2020 d'après la presse américaine
dont le Wall Street Journal Le
Milliardaire républicain ne se mobilise
pas tant d'ailleurs pour les candidats
congrès que pour lui-même avec la
prochaine présidentielle déjà en ligne
de mire comme en témoignent ces attaques
répétées ces derniers jours contre deux
autres figures majeures du camp
républicain et susceptible de se
présenter à la prochaine présidentielle
de 2024 run De Santis le gouverneur de
Fleury des sons
présidents makep pence on ne se quitte
pas là-dessus Elan mais rapidement s'il
vous plaît avant de vous dire à tout à
l'heure est très rapidement je vous
propose de jeter un style au New York
Times qui à cette info pour les
passionnés d'astrophysiques le journal
rapporte que des astronomes viennent de
découvrir un trou noir dans notre
arrière cours cosmique c'est-à-dire à
seulement 1600 années-lumière de la
Terre c'est à dire la porte à côté à
l'échelle cosmique mais pas d'affolement
Pauline la bonne nouvelle c'est que ce
trou noir cet ogre cosmique semble
endormie en sommeil du moins pour le
moment pour le moment merci beaucoup
Hélène à tout à l'heure